billiger tanken für 9 euro monatlich den
nahverkehr nutzen einen sommer lang
sollen die bürger und bürgerinnen
weniger geld ausgeben müssen die
inflation steigt aber weiter bei jedem
einkauf deutlich spürbar familien müssen
gut haushalten in diesen zeiten der
staat ist dabei nicht unbedingt ein
gutes vorbild denn die verschuldung die
steigt weiter der haushalt über den in
dieser woche im bundestag diskutiert
wird umfasst knapp 500 milliarden euro
und das sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr das kommt noch dazu hohe
schulden explodierende preise was plant
die politik unser thema in der phoenix
runde
phoenix runde
die preise für benzin und diesel für
lebensmittel und zurzeit sind steigen
rasant und millionen bürgerinnen und
bürger fragen sich jeden tag komme ich
ihn mit meinem geld reicht es noch am
monatsende
das sind sehr sehr sehr gravierende
fragen fragen auf die es in der tat eine
klare antwort braucht die
bundesregierung umfangreiche entlastung
der bürgerinnen und bürgern unternehmen
auf den weg gebracht in der summe reden
wir über mehr als 30 milliarden euro und
diese entlastungen kommen jetzt an in
den nächsten tagen und wochen sie kommen
jetzt an eben mit dem neuen euro ticket
mit dem tank rabatt überall das sprechen
wir herzlich willkommen aus berlin ich
darf ihnen meine gäste vorstellen alle
hier waren heute im bundestag geredet ja
jeder einzeln und nacheinander wir
sorgen jetzt für das gespräch
miteinander für die ampelkoalition
annika klose von der spd seit 2021 im
bundestag sie ist mitglied im ausschuss
für arbeit und soziales da auch für das
bürgergeld zuständig und sie war juso
vorsitzende in berlin und otto fricke
ist hier haushaltspolitischer sprecher
der fdp-bundestagsfraktion ist schon
lange auch im bundestag für den haushalt
zuständig 2003 als sie anfingen da lag
der bundeshaushalt bei 247 milliarden
also mit weniger fliegen ja für die
opposition gesine lötzsch die linke
haushaltspolitische sprecherin und
stellvertretende vorsitzende ihrer
fraktion und für die cdu csu dr thorsten
frei erster parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer
frau loth jetzt haben wir das eben
gehört klar heute erst der juni all
diese entlastungen sollen jetzt greifen
das muss doch jemanden wie sie
eigentlich freuen dass man die
bürgerinnen und bürger entlastet sind ja
das ist aber ein strohfeuer also dass
neun euro ticket es prima wenn man davon
aber ausgeben musste das ist dann nach
drei monaten wieder vorbei ist und die
leute natürlich enttäuscht und sagen was
passiert jetzt also es ist ein richtiger
schritt den öffentlichen
personennahverkehr preisgünstig zu
machen die menschen auch zu ermuntern
umzusteigen aber das ist natürlich auch
in ordnung so gar kein öffentlicher
nahverkehr ist auf dem dorf nutzt mir
das gar nichts wenn kein bus kommt der
tank rabatt das ist ja eine ganz andere
geschichte da haben wir ja gesehen dass
die preise in den letzten tagen enorm
gestiegen sind und wir wissen ja auch
dass die konzerne die mineralölkonzerne
ungeheuer gewinne machen und das war der
falsche weg und man kann natürlich auch
das hat dann gibt es auch in anderen
ländern in dieser krise beschlossen
staatliche preisregulierung machen das
hatten wir in deutschland ja übrigens
auch bis 2005 strom und energie
preisregulierung und da muss den deckel
drauf und das ist für uns eine ganz
wichtige forderung sonst schießen die
preise weiter durch die decke die einen
werdende mama und die anderen verdienen
sich dumm und dämlich der freak die fdp
wollte vor allen dingen diesen tank
rabatt das heißt diejenigen die die
großen autos haben die viel sprit
verbrauchen die werden jetzt am besten
entlastet wie passt das eigentlich zur
fdp dass der staat so viel aufwand also
die ursprungsidee von uns war eine
andere aber das war der kompromiss den
wir getroffen haben in der frage wie
machen willst und da hat gesehen
deutschland den punkt gebracht wir
müssen auf der einen seite gucken dass
wir den öffentlichen personennahverkehr
für diejenigen die ihn auch nutzen
können dann attraktiver machen die dann
auch die möglichkeit haben
preisgünstiger auf den öpnv umzusteigen
aber mussten auf der anderen seite auch
dafür sorgen dass diejenigen auto
brauchen entlastet werden da hätte es
mehrere möglichkeiten gegeben eine hat
sich ausgeschlossen die viele gedacht
haben lass uns das doch mit der
mehrwertsteuer machen das geht
europarechtlich nicht das machen der in
europa machen das klingt aber
dementsprechend den entsprechenden ärger
mit der kommission weil es nicht geht
der eigentliche vorschlag den wir hatten
es mit einem anderen system zu machen
der hat keine mehr gefunden und dann
muss man eben gucken wenn ich sage ich
muss entlasten muss ich für mehrere
dinge sorgen erstens ich muss dafür
sorgen dass es möglichst fair vorgeht
das kann ich aber an der stelle nicht
machen wenn ich nicht dass etwa über die
pendlerpauschale noch stärker machen
kann und das war dann unsere lösung ich
hätte mir noch mehr andere vorstellen
können aber wir sind eine
dreier-koalition da macht man
kompromisse das ist der gefundene und
jetzt und das ist wichtig geht es darum
dass das was wir auch sagen was gesenkt
wird auch wirklich weiter gegeben wird
da ist eine harte aufgabe für das
kartellamt und da sage ich auch deutlich
das gehört zur sozialen marktwirtschaft
dann auch dazu dass sich da keiner einen
reibach machen trotzdem ist ja die frage
von wie viel muss der starter auffangen
in diesen schwierigen zeiten der frei
sie heute in der debatte gesagt die
glaubwürdigkeit der fdp die schmilzt
schneller als eis in der sonne was
werfen sie den liberalen denn davor na
ja es geht zum einen darum dass man auch
die symptome natürlich dieser
herausforderungen adressiert deswegen
sind entlastungspaket für diejenigen die
besonders getroffen sind sicherlich
richtig das gilt für berufspendler vor
allen dingen im ländlichen raum es gilt
aber auch für diejenigen die schmale
einkommen haben deswegen ist er
auffallend dass gerade rentner und
studenten beispielsweise von vielen
dieser möglichkeit nicht partizipieren
können und das zweite thema das meinte
ich im hinblick auf die fdp es geht
natürlich auch darum dass das
eingesetzte geld möglichst zielgerichtet
ausgegeben wird weil wir machen enorm
viele schulden wenn sie alles
zusammenrechnen in diesem jahr etwa 300
milliarden euro und das reizt natürlich
auch die geldentwertung an das ist eine
fiskalpolitik die am ende dazu führt
dass inflation größer wird und das darf
man glaube ich nicht übersehen wir haben
in den letzten zwei jahren eine
inflation von über 11 prozent in
deutschland gehabt und das bedeutet eben
dass viele arbeiter rentner aber auch
sparer besonders belastet werden und das
muss man auch im blick haben also es
geht nicht nur über kämpfe um die
symptome sind trotzdem grundsätzlich
dafür dass man jetzt eben entlastet weil
es zb magazin gewählt was wir zum
beispiel nicht gemacht hätten wäre das
neun euro ticket das kostet auch
zweieinhalb milliarden euro
bringt aber nichts in der konkreten
situation wir haben keine gestiegenen
medien doch etwas wenn wir jetzt auf
einmal nicht mehr so viel zahlen oder
auch leute die in eier haben also es
bringt deshalb nichts weil das bereiche
gibt in deutschland da nützt es nichts
wenn das ticket neuen euro kurs und wenn
kein bus oder kein zug fährt und auf der
anderen seite sind dort die preise ja
nicht gestiegen anders als an den
zapfsäulen frau klose ist was sagen sie
zum entlastungspaket gerade auch an
diesem wenn man auf den tank rabatt
schaut da werden eben alle gleich
behandelt wie gerecht ist es ja ich
glaube dass die entlassungs pakete
insgesamt stimmig sind um auf die
situation jetzt reagieren zu können und
thema tank rabatt na ja da gab es ja
verschiedene varianten diskutiert wurden
rabatte war das eine also insgesamt
quasi gutscheine zu verteilen oder der
decke den colleges angesprochen hat aber
die frage die wir uns gestellt haben war
ja auch wie schaffen wir es denn eben
nicht die konzerne quasi zu
subventionieren die ja gerade teilweise
auch tatsächlich milliardengewinne
machen die ölkonzerne und gleichzeitig
aber die verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher zu überlasten die ja
teilweise einfach auf ihr auto
angewiesen sind um zur arbeit zu kommen
da haben wir den weg geben der
steuersenkung gewählt und heute sieht
man ja schon an den zapfsäulen dass die
preise auch deutlich runtergegangen sind
aber wir wollten eben auch nicht nur
erstmal ruhe und er war eben auch dass
das kartellamt guckt da ja ganz genau
drauf und außerdem wollen wir ja auch
gerade mit dem neuen euro ticket es
ermöglichen dass man jetzt eben auch
umsteigen kann wo die preise gerade so
hoch sind eben zusätzliche anreize zu
schaffen auf die öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel umzusteigen
gerade auch zur ferienzeit muss man
sagen das kommt den familien ja auch
sehr entgegen die auch gerade in der
panini zeit auch sehr zurückstecken
mussten das ist also nur zusätzliche
entlastung wird entgegenkommen und der
dritte aspekt ist ja auch noch das
energie gilt was an alle
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
ausgezahlt wird in höhe von 300 euro und
das stellt den ja quasi frei wie also
welche energieformen sie quasi verwenden
auch zur mobilität und werden darüber ja
auch entlastet also ich glaube es ist
eigentlich gut ausgewogen also es ist
natürlich nicht ausgewogen weil das
energie geld ist ja schon angesprochen
worden nicht bei allen ankommt also es
kann mir niemand erklären warum
rentnerinnen und rentner und studierende
dieses energie geld nicht bekommen
studierende und rentnerinnen und rentner
bekommen ja wenn sie niedriger einkommen
haben den heizkostenzuschuss er ja ja es
ist aber es wird auch als große
ungerechtigkeit empfunden und wir haben
ja festgestellt dass hat er die
bundesregierung entsprechend beantwortet
dass zum beispiel das ganze kabinett die
ministerin und minister selbst der
bundeskanzler bekommt das energie geld
aber oma anna die wirklich ihre rente
zusammen zählen muss die bekommen sie
sagen noch um das muss ich sagen das ist
jetzt unfair wenn oma anna sie zusammen
zählen muss und damit in dem bereich ist
wo sie nicht ausreichen trend hat dann
bekommt sie ja die entsprechende
leistung aus dem jeweiligen system dazu
deswegen
würden wir müssen schon früh haben
ausreichend geld und japan tragen jetzt
mich ehrlich mich interessiert bei der
frage wie man helfen muss nicht ob
jemand anders auch etwas bekommt mich
interessiert ob ich dem schwachen helfen
wenn sie sagen den schwachen wird nicht
geholfen dann stimmt das einfach nicht
weil wir dann in den systemen dafür
gesorgt haben dass diejenigen die
übrigens als renner wenn sie einkommen
haben dann kriegen sie es das ist nur
eine gruppe von ungefähr vier millionen
rentnern aber auch die bekommen ist ich
muss differenzieren ein sozialstaat
heißt dort wo das geld nicht ausreicht
und muss der sozialstaat effektiv die
leistung die zusätzlichen leistungen
bringen das passiert in empfehlen die
gerade beschrieben sind und bei den an
das sage ich dann auch die 300 sind ja
nicht für alle gleich denn hier wird ja
brutto mit netto verwechselt von sehr
sehr vielen da ist es dann ja auch
gerade richtungen das finde ich dann
noch in ordnung aber das muss in der
produktion machen die transfergerüchte
hinein sondern es geht ja wirklich um
die kleine rente und das kleine einhorn
das für sie denn eine kleine rente ja
wenn man wenig geld zur verfügung hat
und das sind im jahr das sind im zweifel
diejenigen die kurz oberhalb der
grundrente sind beispielsweise das sind
ja die die bei uns herzlich willkommen
sind auch wenn sie haben selbst wenn sie
kurz oberhalb muss man natürlich die
frage sind wir bereit uns zu verschulden
und auch den generationen danach die
jüngeren generation schulden zu
hinterlassen ich würde jetzt ganz gerne
mal den oppositionsführer dazu hören das
war heute eine muntere haushaltsdebatte
und da ging es noch mal um das wort
zeitenwende vom das hat der
oppositionsführer friedrich merz
eingebracht es gibt nichts was sie außer
neuen schulden mit diesem wort zeigt
wenn wir zeitenwende
alles
[Musik]
doch so schön bleiben wie sie es in
ihrem koalitionsvertrag der mittlerweile
nur noch ins archiv gehört wie sie in
ihrem koalitionsvertrag verabredet haben
im gegenteil aus ihren reihen kommen
fast im wochenrhythmus neue vorschläge
wie man zusätzliches geld ausgibt der
jüngste vorschlag ihres sozialministers
ein soziales klima geld für einkommen
bis 1000 euro im monat
schauen sie sich die reihen dieser
koalition an bei diesem wort soziales
klima gehen welche reaktionen dass hier
im haus aus listen sondern ich muss das
jetzt
das ist schon ganz interessant sind die
volkspartei noch ein bisschen läuft aber
setzen sich
für dieses thema
haben sie ihn geklatscht haben thema
klima geld na ja also ich hab bei der
rede von herrn merz nicht gekriegt und
was man zu stellen aber die frage oder
die richtige überlegung von hubertus
heil besteht ja darin dass man menschen
direkt etwas gibt und die fdp möchte ja
gerne mal so den leuten etwas nebel ins
gesicht blasen sagen naja wir senken die
steuern aber es gibt ja viele leute mit
einem sehr geringen einkommen die von
steuersenkungen überhaupt nichts haben
weil sie also von einkommen- und
lohnsteuer senkung weil sie davon nicht
profitieren also ist die idee menschen
direkt zu unterstützen wie das umberto
sei ja vorgeschlagen hat richtig das
problem besteht nur darin dass er sofort
der finanzminister christian lindner
gesagt hat
wo ist denn die gegenfinanzierung und
damit hat er das abgeräumt weil den
vielen neuen schulden bei den vielen bei
den vielen neuen schulden die jetzt
gemacht wurden unter dem finanzminister
lindner hättet hätte die fdp wäre sie
noch in der opposition gewesen ihr wert
der im quadrat gesprungen
und hinzu kommen natürlich noch wenn ich
den einsatz noch sagen darf aufkommen
habe schon noch das eigen 100 milliarden
sondervermögen ist ja kein vermögen das
sind ja extra schulden wie kommen wir
noch unter genau aber man muss ja sagen
dass das klima geld auch schon im
koalitionsvertrag verankert war und das
ist ja auch sinnvoll weil es eben nicht
nur auf die situation jetzt reagiert
sondern eben auch auf den klimawandel
und die klimaanpassung die wir annehmen
müssen wo wir davon ausgehen dass eben
gewisse aspekte des lebens eben auch
teurer werden und gerade menschen mit
geringen oder gar kein einkommen also
quasi sozialhilfe oder transfer hilfe
kriegen dass die halt mitgenommen werden
müssen aber was meist gar nicht
mitgenommen fröhlich kann doch nicht für
alles was wo ich ein problem habe immer
wieder neue schulden machen also sie als
ehemalige juso vorsitzende müssen doch
sozusagen die ehe die junge generation
auch noch wirklich im blick das wundert
mich ja ja aber was heißt denn man kann
nicht für alles neue schulden machen
stimmt man kann nicht für alles neue
schulden machen man muss auch gucken wie
man es finanziert einmal der keine frage
und darüber werden wir in der koalition
sicherlich auch noch viel sprechen aber
man muss auch sagen dass große
zukunftsinvestition eben auch
ihnen werden müssen von einem großteil
der bevölkerung so funktioniert
demokratie ja eben das muss mehrheiten
geben und das hilft halt nicht wenn wir
gerade den teil der bevölkerung hinten
runterfallen lassen der das ist halt
nicht mehr leisten kann und die armut
wächst und man muss ja sagen das geld
was man gerade für menschen zur
verfügung stellt die von transfer hilfe
leben oder sehr geringe einkommen haben
geht fast zu 100 prozent in den konsum
aber das erste ass energie geht ist heiß
lauf direkt ist ja dazu geführt werden
sind ja nicht sehr geringe einkommen das
klima geldsorgen für einzelpersonen bis
deswegen keine geringverdiener aber was
jedoch aussehen müssen alles was wir
über kredite finanzieren sind die
steuern für zukünftige generationen und
das muss man natürlich schon sagen wir
haben sehr viel finanziert im
zusammenhang mit der bekämpfung der
kogit 19 pandemie und es geht jetzt eins
zu eins weiter und eines muss man schon
ganz klar sagen auch spätere
generationen werden mit besonderen
herausforderungen
konfrontiert sein also wir dürfen uns
glaube ich auch nicht anmaßen zu glauben
dass die herausforderungen die wir zu
bewältigen haben singulär sind das ist
die vorher und nachher nicht gab er kann
aber auch nicht glauben dass wenn
infrastruktur zum beispiel kaputtgespart
ist dass das eine zukunft und situation
ist ähnlich hoher investitionen in die
investitionen gesagt zum thema die
bundeswehr ist offensichtlich in einem
schlechten ausrüstung zusammen steckt ja
doch möglicherweise schon festgestellt
dann ist doch klar wenn wir in der
situation sind wir jetzt das da
ausgerüstet werden muss wenn wir sehen
dass in städten teilweise jede dritte
brücke kaputtes dass kommunen
altschulden haben wo sie nicht
hinterherkommt
die muss man doch angehen
schulen die sich aber auch für meine
generation am ende dann halt auszahlen
weil ich sage dass ich nicht aus wenn
ich will erklären wenn ich vielleicht
war ja und so schön gesagt wo ist was
die fdp gegeben wir einfach noch mal nur
zu den fakten also das erste ist der
hubertus heil ist sehr geschickt ich
kenne robert sehr sehr lange da steht im
koalitionsvertrag und deswegen ist er
auch nicht für irgendein archiv übrigens
wenn dann digital da steht drin klima
geld gibt es und das ist gemeint damit
dass dort wo der staat über die co2
abgabe mehr geld einnimmt er dieses auch
pro kraft zurück gibt hubertus heil
macht daraus ein klima geld für leute
die fünfstellige steuern im jahr
bezahlung das nur klar zu machen wenn
sie ein verheiratetes paar haben die die
entsprechenden 8000 verdienen dann
kommen sie auf einen fünfstelligen
steuerbetrag da sag ich dann ganz klar
wenn man die entlasten will dann doch
bitte in dem man steuern senkt und nicht
indem man die steuern hält und sagt ich
gebe dir von deinen eigenen steuern wenn
das geld so das ist der punkt 1.2 den
will ich doch an der stelle ganz klar
und deutlich machen wir haben und
deswegen habe ich als fdp auch kein im
quadrat springen wir haben eine
notsituation der hat die cdu auch noch
für das ja 21 zugestimmt dass die in 22
angeblich nicht mehr besteht kann ich
persönlich nicht sehen und das ist das
was entscheidend beim haushalt ist du
musst in der zeit sparen wenn keine
notsituation ist um in der nutzer haben
deswegen habe ich da auch keine
schwierigkeit in diesem jahr das zu tun
die entscheidende frage ist und da bin
ich ein ich was machen wir wenn wir im
nächsten jahr 2023 keine notsituation
wir haben das wird anstrengend das ist
ja die frage wir hätten ja auch nicht
mit diesem krieg gerechnet wir hätten
dich mit kronen gerechnet also die frage
ist wo kommen wir denn überhaupt zeiten
wo man wirklich noch eher war es die
einnahmen erhöhen das ist doch völlig
klar statt neue schulden zu machen
müssen wir die einnahmen irgendwie macht
und dann ja das ist etwas was ja auch
innerhalb der koalition wird es auch in
dieser woche gesehen haben noch
diskutiert wird also zum einen haben wir
ja gesehen dass in der krisenzeit sowohl
in der korona krise als jetzt auch in
den weiteren krisen es leute gibt die
unheimlich viel gewinne machen die
anzahl der milliardäre hat sie
vergrößert in deutschland seit der
korona krise und da muss man auch sagen
da müssen steuern erhoben werden und
dann haben wir die so lange auf den
spitzensteuersatz dann haben wir die
situation dass es über gewinne gibt in
italien zum beispiel hat man über gewinn
steuer eingeführt und da müssen wir ran
da haben wir dann auch potenzial um
wichtige dinge investitionen markus
conrad vom wem wer sollen mehr bezahlen
sozusagen eine einkommensgrenze sie sagt
nur bestimmten als würden sie haben ja
schon vorgeschlagen dass es eine
vermögensabgabe gibt für die reichsten
0,7 prozent der bevölkerung das ist
glaube ich da muss niemand angst haben
dass ihm irgendwas weggenommen wird
wofür er lange gespart hat und für die
reichsten 0,7 prozent der bevölkerung
davon jedes jahr 0,7 nein die reichsten
0,7 prozent der betroffenen zahlen wie
viel prozent pro jahr die bezahlen keine
prozente pro jahr sondern die bezahlen
über einen längeren zeitraum eine
größere vermögensabgabe die sie gut
verkraften können das kann man über 20
jahre strecken über 30 jahre aber es ist
eine größere summe die dann zusammen
kommen aber ansehen dann großen ordnung
ja na klar mir deine größenordnung das
ist ja auch klar also diese
vermögensabgabe wie möglich die
vermögensabgabe soll so viel wie möglich
und das mögliche besteht wurden dass sie
das die leute eben nicht
beeinträchtigt werden sondern das was
sie wirklich über haben abgeben können
ganz einfach sagen deswegen dass er
jetzt noch einmal zulegen sie selber
fest also mit jemand zehn millionen hat
niemals zehn millionen hat dann soll er
wie viel abnehmen also wir haben diese
rechnung vorgelegt zusammen die wie
berechnet dass man wenn man das über
viele jahre streckt das sehr erträglich
ist
klare antwort aber aber was in diesem
zusammenhang vielleicht auch wichtig ist
bevor die pandemie kam haben wir sieben
jahre ausgeglichene haushalte gehabt die
haben sogar altschulden getilgt wir
haben die
schuldenbelastung des staates von über
80 prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts auf
unter 60 prozent gesenkt also ist der
schwarze null und da sagen viele die
haben viel zu wenig investiert und
deshalb haben ein problem regierung weil
das schweigen radeln in den letzten
jahren dieser zeit wird die höchsten
investitionen
in die höchsten investitionen in
investitionsgüter hatten aber was glaube
ich auch wichtig ist die frau löst das
problem dadurch dass man einfach die
einnahmesituation verändert
die
bundespolitik gehört zunächst einmal
dass man prioritäten setzt und das haben
wir die letzten zehn jahre verlernt weil
wir jedes jahr höhere steuereinnahmen
hatten als im vorjahr haben sie nicht
offen allen
selbst
genau das hat friedrich merz in diesem
beitrags ausschnitt gemeint den sie eben
gezeigt haben dass es darum geht das
wenn wir eine so fundamental geänderte
situation haben wenn wir gemeinsam der
auffassung sind jedenfalls die meisten
im parlament dass wir 100 milliarden für
die bundeswehr brauchen dass das nicht
geht dass man ansonsten alles beim alten
lässt dann muss man auch die politik
ändern muss prioritäten festsetzen und
daneben auch nachrangigkeit es geht
nicht dass man alles macht aber auf der
einen seite zu sagen wir wollen den
solidaritätszuschlag abschaffen das bei
im wahlkampf ganz wichtig und jetzt zu
sagen wir brauchen jetzt doch ein er hat
es als ein eine finanzierungsmöglichkeit
gesehen jedenfalls glaube ich das ist ja
sozusagen das gegenmodell also wir
machen das alles heute wir machen
richtigerweise die ausrüstung der
bundeswehr
wir lassen alle projekte im
koalitionsvertrag weiterlaufen wie
bisher
wir haben aber umgekehrt nicht die kraft
entsprechende steuereinnahmen zu
verändern also verschieden wir alles auf
das nicht
zu dem soli was halten sie davon wenn
man versucht und auch auf der einen
seite den plan von frau loth also
irgendwie um einnahmen zu erhöhen und
damit das ungerecht verteilt naja dass
die spd für die erhöhung der
einnahmeseite ist das ist ja kein
geheimnis damit sind auch wir ja in den
wahlkampf gezogen also vermögenssteuer
hoch war ja auch etwas was wir wollten
und die erbschaftssteuer darauf haben
wir uns jetzt in der koalition nicht
verständigen können aber natürlich dass
man sich das angucken muslim anhalt das
miteinander löst ist natürlich die frage
und ich denke dass man da natürlich an
der einen oder anderen stelle abwägung
treffen kann aber es kann halt auch
nicht sein dass wir als stadt und sind
stellen und sagen wir können es uns
leisten dass die menschen hier ohne
strom ohne heizung leben oder sich die
lebensmittel nicht mehr leisten können
also es muss sich ja auch die waage
halten und da haben wir einfach auch
eine verantwortung und der staat ist nun
eben ja nun auch keine schwäbische
hausfrau quasi sondern staatsschulden
sind ja schon was anderes und wenn die
wirtschaft läuft und wenn wir es
schaffen dass mehr menschen in arbeit
kommen zwar auch
sozialversicherungspflichtige arbeit
dann entlastet das den haushalt ja auch
wieder also wir müssen noch dafür sorgen
dass das funktioniert und deswegen finde
ich zum beispiel ein vorschlag der
konzentrierten aktion die herr scholz
jetzt gemacht hat also arbeitgeber
arbeitnehmer an einen tisch zu holen und
gemeinsam darauf dass zu besprechen wie
man jetzt vorgeht ist doch genau der
richtige weg den wir jetzt einschlagen
müssen nun kommen wir gleich zu dieser
konzertierten aktion aber jetzt nochmal
ich muss noch mal muss ich weiß dass das
viele nerven denn so jemand wie ich als
haushalte die rechenmaschine anwirft der
neue mercedes neuer märz soli in das
muss man einfach nur sehen wenn der dazu
dienen soll das bundeswehr vermögen zu
finanzieren das jedes jahr 20 milliarden
zusätzlich ausgibt dann bedeutet das ich
brauche jedes jahr 20 milliarden aus dem
süden und das bedeutet in ungefähr das
was der soli bevor er halbiert worden
ist gemacht hat das heißt jeder bürger
weiß der märz soli kostet so viel wie
ich früher soli gezahlt habe ist
mathematisch ganz einfach darzustellen
ich brauche 20 milliarden ich habe aus
dem soli wenn ich in insgesamt gemacht
hätte ungefähr 20 milliarden was ich
aber deutlich noch mal sagen will ist
die frage die muss politik immer immer
doch am ende sagen es gibt nicht
unendlich geld länder die gesagt haben
es gibt unendlich geldern ja gerade ja
das ist übrigens das problem und da
stimme ich insoweit in der analyse zu
wir hatten die griechenlandkrise die
bankenkrise die europa krise die chronik
risiko keine krise und trotzdem haben
was irgendwo hingekriegt ja aber auch
indem wir in der notsituation schulden
gemacht haben nur mit der folge dass
sich das dann eben auf die inflation
ausgewirkt alle haben übrigens das finde
ich interessant keiner gesagt jetzt mehr
ich kann bei der mine wird die inflation
geben auf einmal sagen alles ist ihm die
die vor inflation gewarnt haben gehört
dass friedrich herz ehrlicherweise auto
und auch christian lindner christian
denen wurde nicht geglaubt jetzt
bekommen wir das und das ist die größte
gefahr den inflation ist ein mieser
verräter denn inflation trifft die
kleinen am stärksten weil sie am besten
reagieren kann man muss aber auch sagen
die inflation hat ja gerade mehrere
ursachen und einer ist zum beispiel dass
wir die mehrwertsteuer 3 prozent
abgesenkt hatten in den letzten die
jetzt wieder hoch kommt dann sind das
eben die lieferketten unterbrochen sind
beispielsweise
nach folgen der pandemie die
konjunkturprogramme es kommt ja viel
zusammen und es ist ja schon davon
auszugehen dass es jetzt nicht auf
diesem hohen niveau bleiben wird
dauerhaft er warum erstens weiß nicht
ich bin froh dass sie das wissen ich
sage ganz ehrlich es gibt viele gründe
für die inflation ja aber sie hat viel
früher angefangen als das was er jetzt
mit der ukraine nach erleben und wenn
wir ehrlich sind dann müssen wir doch
sie eine inflation kommt dadurch dass am
ende die reale leistung nicht mehr dem
geld entspricht das dahinter steht und
das ist das problem da hat die ezb in
der aufgabe die jungs über jahre gesagt
hat es kommt keine inflation bin ich
auch ziemlich sauer darauf weiß noch von
gesprächen wo ich als kleiner dover
haushälter gesagt hab irgendwann kommt
die inflation sind müssen hast du das
wird jetzt nicht locker sein ich glaube
dass die geschichte mit dem soli für die
bundeswehr eine ironische bemerkung in
richtung
haushälter der koalition sein sollte
aber man sieht natürlich dass nicht
jeder gezündet sich verselbstständigt
aber die eigentliche frage ist doch da
kommen die sind ja schon wieder bei
diesem sondervermögen bundeswehr wer
bezahlt denn diese schulden das sind ja
auch schuld und wenn gesagt wird das
sind schulden die schulden soll man
nicht der nächsten generation
weitergeben dann sind das gerade diese
bundeswehr schulden die so vernebelt
werden und verschleiert werden unter dem
schönen titel sondervermögen dann muss
ganz deutlich sagen das sind extra
schulden und das sind schulden für die
bundeswehr bzw schulden für die
aufrüstung und das finde ich natürlich
aber in ordnung weil ich richtig lt
bundeswehr mehr geld bekommen also die
bundeswehr hat oder die politiker die
bundeswehr selber ja gar nicht hat den
eindruck versucht zu erwecken als hätte
sie über jahre kein geld bekommen es ist
so dass der bundeshaushalt für die
bundeswehr bzw für verteidigung über die
jahre immer wieder aufgewachsen ist aber
nicht hält messe sei gesagt ihr seid
seid stolz finanzminister ist ist das in
summe gewesen ist es ja ganz was in
summe 38,5 milliarden wir sind jetzt bei
50 milliarden für den verteidigungsetat
und man muss sich doch mal fragen wo ist
denn das viele geld geblieben dass wir
fragen sich natürlich auch die
soldatinnen und soldaten
es ist ja unheimlich viel geld immer
wieder rein gesteckt worden und dann ist
sind verträge geschlossen worden mit
rüstungsfirmen die nicht mal klauseln
hatten dass sie nicht bezahlt werden
müssen wenn die dinge die sie liefern
nicht funktionieren also das sind doch
alles dinge die muss man da auch mal
aufklären können aber so ist es ja jeder
sagen man kann ja okay also das kann
natürlich akzeptieren dass man in greven
keinen fall sagt ja ist es so da ist das
geld verschwunden das interessiert uns
nicht wie bei hansa jetzt mal ganz genau
die ja ich dachte ich sage nochmal muss
ja jetzt reagieren herr frey es gab
jetzt heute abend nochmal auf einmal ein
bisschen unruhe am freitag soll darüber
abgestimmt werden es ist auf einmal die
union will jetzt doch nicht zustimmen
was ist denn da der stand dann sollen
das war nicht das war tatsächlich nicht
so sondern auch sieben also ich muß ich
war bei der fahndung dabei und dann
nehme ich das jetzt mal reichen das
gehört auch dazu die cdu csu hatte noch
ein paar berechtigte fragen weil wir sie
brauchen dabei mitzumachen diese fragen
sind technisch im detail beantwortet
worden das ist ich finde das immer sehr
witzig ist hoch gespielt wurde aber da
sage ich ganz offen nein es war ein
faires verhandeln fragen wurden
nachgestellt fragen wurden beantwortet
cdu hat gesagt dann können wir das jetzt
auch so über schließlich kann sie ganz
exakt sagen die texte für die
gesetzesänderung die haben wir gestern
abend um 16 uhr 51 bekommen und ich
finde das ist das aller normalste von
der welt dass wir uns ein paar stunden
zeit nehmen um uns das anzuschauen
deswegen waren wir nicht bereit eine
sondersitzung des haushaltsausschusses
heute vormittag zu akzeptieren sondern
wir machen sie heute oder haben sie
heute abend 19 gemacht genauso ist ja
bereits vorbei und wir haben dem
zugestimmt und deswegen kann man das
auch am freitag machen aber also
schnelligkeit und gründlichkeit das sind
zwei seiten einer medaille
und an der union lag es nicht dass wird
der herr fricke bestätigen können an der
fdp glaube ich auch nicht wir hätten uns
auch schon zwei monate früher also schon
vor ostern verständigen können auf genau
dieser basis und wenn es jetzt so lange
gedauert hat dann muss man nicht in
wenigen stunden die entscheidung treffen
die haben immer gesagt wir stehen dem
nicht im weg wir machen das schnellst
möglich aber es muss solide sein und das
ist auch unsere voran freitag wird
darüber abgestimmt ich gern mal einen
anderen also auf ein anderes wort kommen
nämlich dieses schöne worte
schuldenbremse und schwarze null wie
sollen wir denn in zukunft mit dem
haushalt umgehen follett was wäre ihnen
sehr wichtig wenn man sagt er fricke
sagt spare in der zeit dann hast du in
der not gehen sie damit wissen will
grundsätzlich wieder versuchen das zu
reduzieren wir müssen an den richtigen
stellen sparen und an den richtigen
stellen investieren weil wir gerade
gesehen haben auch in den zeiten der
krise wie kurzsichtig ja viele sachen
auch gemacht wurde dass wir viele
öffentliche sachen ja auch nicht
vorgehalten haben und stimmig frau klose
völlig zu wir müssen investieren auch
für zukünftige investoren generationen
und wenn wir uns jetzt dem zustand zum
beispiel unserer schulen anschauen da
fielen 45 milliarden euro mit 45
milliarden euro könnten wir unsere
schulen das ist für die schulen leben
wir haben wir eine gesamtverantwortung
dann könnten wir
das sozusagen in ordnung bringen das hat
uns die kfw auch vorgerechnet die
kreditanstalt für wiederaufbau also wir
müssen vor allen dingen die dinge
langfristig sichern die wir auch in
zukunft brauchen und können nicht sagen
also okay ihr habt jetzt mal kaputtes
haus liebe kinder und liebe
nachfolgenden generationen aber dafür
gibt es keine schulden werden das ist ja
eine viel größere belastung für die
künftige generation aber grund zur
freude vor klose wie würden sie sagen
wie wichtig ist es dass man wieder ja
dass man wieder eine haushaltspolitik
machen und die schwarze null wichtig ist
dass man eben nicht sich noch mehr
verschuldet ja mir person ist es das
muss ich sagen ja ich bin kein fan der
schwarzen null ich weiß wie eingeführt
war dagegen die jusos habe ich damals
dagegen demonstriert dann werde ich mich
jetzt nicht da hinstellen und sagen wir
brauchen das unbedingt ich bin der
meinung dass der staat über steuern
indem beispielsweise insbesondere in
zeiten wo es wirtschaftlich gut läuft
eben einnahmen einnehmen kann und auch
sollte und hohe einkommen eben
entsprechend auch in die pflicht nehmen
sollte und entsprechend halt wenn es
schwierig ist also wenn wir in der krise
stecken investieren aber auch
langfristige investitionen tätigen
können ich bin gerne tiere mit der
koalition zusammen also die
ampelkoalition ist es da also stand ich
darauf verständigen können außerdem
hätten wir dafür gar keine mehrheit die
schuldenbremse auszusetzen dafür
brauchen nämlich eine
zweidrittelmehrheit das steht im
grundgesetz von daher stets gerade gar
nicht zur debatte aber man sieht ja wie
schnell man das grundgesetz ändern kann
und die schuldenbremse im grundgesetz
halte ich persönlich auch von schweren
fehler dass es haben ja viele inzwischen
auch ökonomen die gar nicht als links
verortet werden sagen die schuldenbremse
ökonomischer überblick die entscheidende
frage ist doch wie stabil ist die
infrastruktur wie wenn man damit auch
die die frage kümmern sichern und das
glaube ich darauf müssen wir uns
konzentrieren und wir müssen natürlich
unsere einnahmen stabilisieren bzw
erhöhen man erlebt was jetzt passiert
und das sage ich beim thema sparen immer
jeder versteht um das sparen was anderes
und jeder der uns jetzt zuhört er muss
sich selber fragen was wäre denn wenig
sparen müsste sage ich dann wo kriege
ich mehr geld her oder fragt oder frage
ich steuern oder frage ich wo moment man
kann mehr arbeiten man kann sich
zusätzlich qualifizieren die stimme dazu
bei der frage einer ausgabe führen oder
wofür geld ausgegeben wird ist die frage
für die zukunft bildung forschung
investitionen aber man muss auch fragen
auf was kann euch auf was soll ich auf
was muss ich verzichten denn das
argument was jetzt kommt ist wir müssen
in den normalen zeiten dafür mehr
ausgeben und dafür mehr ausgeben und
dafür mehr ausgebuht in der notzeit
müssen wir dafür und dafür mehr ausgeben
das wird nicht funktionieren und das
zeigt sich über die jahre man macht
immer die ausgaben immer weiter hoch und
glaubt dass das nach zieht das wird
nicht funktionieren die schuldenbremse
ist ja gut und übrigens weil hier gesagt
wird schwarze null ich bin kein fan der
schwarzen und ich bin ein fan der
schuldenbremse unserer verfassung und
die sagt übrigens sehr flexibel dass man
in zeiten der not höhere verschuldung
machen kann oder eben eine notsituation
erklären kann wenn sie da ist das ist
nicht ideologisch wir machen jetzt die
notsituation aber wir hätten übrigens im
letzten jahr ohne notsituationen 80
milliarden schulden nach der
schuldenbremse machen können deswegen
ist die ökonomisch gar nicht so schlecht
das mögen nur die leute nicht die ich
sage das immer sehr gerne dann möglichst
viel geld ausgeben wollen und deswegen
das kann man klarstellen also für die
abschaffung oder änderungen bei der
schuldenbremse wird es keine
parlamentarische mehrheit geben dann
braucht man nämlich die union und wir
werden dem mit sicherheit nicht
zustimmen das ist eine frage der
generationengerechtigkeit
das muss man wirklich sagen und das
ausgeben und investieren muss immer auch
ein ponton haben nämlich dass man in den
wirtschaftsstarken zeiten dann eben auch
entsprechend sparsamer mannschaft
eigentlich jetzt dass man viel mehr
hätte investieren müssen
das ist sinnvoll gewesen wäre höhere
schulden zu machen wenn man so viel
früher ein investiert investiert wenn
man in die infrastruktur zum beispiel
auch der bahn investiert hätte ja das
nicht viel sie ja auch nicht über
schulden also die frage ist wofür man
sein geld ausgibt ob man sie für
investive ausgaben oder für konsumtive
ausgaben ausgibt und in den letzten
jahren haben wir deutlich gegengesteuert
bei der infrastruktur bei der analogen
wieder digitalen beispielsweise und es
gehört bei denen die zuständig sind ich
war mal oberbürgermeister beispielsweise
bei den kommunen bei den ländern schon
auch dazu schwerpunkte im
bildungsbereich zu setzen und deswegen
muss man natürlich sagen der
investitionsstau von dem sie gesprochen
haben der ist dem einen land stärker und
dem anderen land weniger stark da kann
man auch nicht alle über einen kamm
scheren und da muss man häufig auch
sagen das sind dann mitunter auch
falsche entscheidungen aber muss es
vielleicht auch dazu sagen dass man
ihnen höhere einnahmen ja auch nicht zu
machen wollen also die vermögenssteuer
zum beispiel haben sie ja auch nicht mit
dem üblichen standard stolpe in
deutschland zum beispiel immer auch
unternehmen haben die sehr hohe gewinne
machen und übrigens auch in den letzten
jahren sehr hohe gewinne gemacht haben
dividende sogar führend ist und bleibt
das löse sie ja es gibt sehr hohe
vermögenswerte in diesem land und die
hängen natürlich auch mit den
unternehmen zusammen nicht nur klar aber
auch sehr hohe privatvermögen und da
könnte man natürlich auch gerade in
zeiten der krise über vermögensabgaben
vermögenssteuern und so weiter die
einnahmenseite
die beide sich da besser verstehen
würden frau lötzsch und frau klose und
sie hätten da ein problem
ja ja ja ich sehe noch wissen aber
ich glaube dass es ein missverständnis
davon was eine koalition ist dieser
versucht zu sagen da regiert einer durch
und dann macht das so weder wir können
das noch die spd kann das ich anziehen
und partei ich akzeptiere die positionen
in der gemeinsamen traten zum klar wo
wir gemeinsam zustimmen gefallen dann
auch und jetzt
aber dafür macht die gruppe 3 nehmen da
wo wir zusammen etwas verändern können
tun wird dass auch das wird die frage
sein investitionen glauben ja viele das
wäre das was so weil die starts vorteile
staatsquote 50 prozent ist wäre auch die
investition 50 prozent das ist aber eins
zu acht zu 9 nachdem wie sie sehen noch
höher wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
private investieren ich sage das ganz
deutlich neben mache ich eine
substanzbesteuerung ist das was ich für
das wichtigste im moment halte nämlich
eine nachhaltige co2 freie wirtschaft zu
erreichen ist nicht möglich wir können
nicht als staat das hinkriegen sie
müssen die unternehmen hinkriegen die
müssen um bei mir im ruhrgebiet duisburg
direkt nebenan die müssen auf
wasserstoff darüber gehen müssen
investieren und nicht über staatliche
subventionen wo ich dem einen vorher das
geld wegnehme um es da schon zu
verteilen das wird die eigentliche
aufgabe sein und da sage ich dann ganz
deutlich wenn ich den anreiz nicht
schaffe schaffe ich das nicht mit der
nachhaltigkeit und gleichzeitig wird oft
vergessen neue technologien sind das
beste gegen inflation weil sich auf der
angebotsseite verändern jetzt hat der
kanzler ich will noch mal auf dieses
wort konzertierte aktionen eingehen und
diese den vorschlag den er gemacht hat
hat eben das gewerkschaften arbeitgeber
zusammen mit dem start das ist ein
masterplan geben soll frei welchen
würden sie sich denn da wünschen wenn
wieder eine regierung werden wir werden
ihre konzertierte aktion ja ich bin
jetzt mal sehr gespannt auf seine seine
vorschläge das problem ist ja er hat es
im zusammenhang mit der geldentwertung
und der entwicklung dort benannt weil es
natürlich naheliegend ist dass die
gewerkschaften in den tarifverhandlungen
versuchen werden höhere lohnabschlüsse
zu erreichen die jedenfalls oberhalb der
inflationsrate sind wenn das passiert
die ig metall hat jetzt glaube ich 8,2
prozent in den raum gestellt dann
bedeutet es aber natürlich dass im
herbst eine lohn-preis-spirale sich in
gang setzt die im zweifel zu einer noch
höheren inflation für dich geh mal davon
aus so habe ich ihn verstanden heute
morgen dass er versucht dieses problem
zu adressieren und da zu einer lösung zu
kommen wo eben die tarifpartner unter
start versuchen einen weg zu finden
wir haben es mit partnern zu tun die
jeweils eigene interessen haben und das
ist natürlich in der sozialen
marktwirtschaft grundsätzlich auch
richtig so was halten sie davon was
erwarten sie ich glaube was was wir in
deutschland mal erkennen müssen dass
unser großer vorteil gegenüber anderen
ländern ist das ist unser unsere
sozialpartnerschaft wir haben
arbeitgeberverbände und gewerkschaften
haben es in den letzten jahren immer
wieder geschafft einerseits dafür zu
sorgen dass auch gute löhne gezahlt
werden aber andere als auch dafür zu
sorgen dass es nicht nach dem motto geht
ist es noch ein bisschen mehr mit der
folge dass dann nachher arbeitsplätze
kaputt gegangen sind wir haben übrigens
eine beschäftigung die so hoch ist trotz
corona wir sie eigentlich noch nie so in
der art hatten was aber jetzt kommen
muss sage ich dann auch ganz klar ist
eine eine vereinbarung die sicherheit
gibt denn die angst vor inflation ist ja
das schlimme ist ja nicht die inflation
selbst sondern die angst davor und die
kann eine konzertierte aktion nehmen
wenn man aber aufpassen dass man nicht
jetzt in den sozialpartnern hier
sozusagen alles wegnimmt da bin ich sehr
froh dass der arbeitgeberpräsident auch
gegenüber den neuen dgb chef schon
gezeigt hat dass man weiter in der
kommunikation als auch sehr konkret also
zum beispiel sind die lebensmittelpreise
im letzten jahr um 33 prozent gestiegen
das ist ja keine angst sondern sind teil
das ist ja einfach wenn man einen
einkauf genau die ist real und die ist
keine angst vor einer inflation und
darum muss man natürlich sehen wie man
menschen und da sind wir über dem thema
was vorhin schon angesprochen hat auch
direkt hilft und da ist ja die frage der
steuerpolitik und dass eine
steuersenkung davon profitieren ja nicht
alle gerade die menschen mit sehr
niedrigen einkommen und darum sind ja
die vorschläge einer direkten
unterstützung von direktzahlungen auch
richtig was los was erwarten sie da naja
also grundlegend unterstütze ich das
natürlich auch dass wir eben und zwar
auf die tarifpartnerschaft verlassen
dass nur durch den jetzt nicht vorgeben
möchte was die jetzt an meine aus
ansonsten kann aber wären sie dafür dass
ich es die löhne eben auch ja ich finde
steigende inflationsrate ja auf jeden
fall ich finde die löhne müssen ganz
dringend steigen und dass die
gewerkschaften dann natürlich einen
punkt haben und ich sehe auch nicht dass
dieser ohne tür steht vor allem dazu da
wäre die gewerkschaften an die kandare
zu nehmen es geht darum eben was
auszuhandeln miteinander was eben am
ende schwer ist weil die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
müssen ja jetzt auch klar kommen mit den
steigenden preisen aber dass die lohn
preis spirale hat ja beide seiten einmal
die löhne steigen und dann ist die frage
wie steigen die preise und dass man eben
dann die preissteigerungen nicht
gleichbedeutend eben weiter reicht dann
müssen halt beide schon auch natürlich
sich dran halten und dran an einem
strang ziehen aber es ist schon auch
wichtig dass die löhne jetzt auch hoch
gehen das kann man sich ja das ja auch
nicht mehr leisten aber dass die
haushalte aber kostet geld und die kunst
im zweifel auch wohlstand das muss man
ganz offen sagen das ist die folge von
ihnen flossen das ist überhaupt die
frage der bundeswirtschaftsminister hat
vor einigen wochen ja gesagt wir werden
alle ärmer werden darauf hat er ja die
bevölkerung sozusagen eingestellt durch
die steigenden energiepreise durch alle
die folgendes des krieges in der in der
ukraine
müsste die politik nicht auch sich ein
stück ehrlicher machen herr fricke und
weil man jetzt ja das gefühl hat immer
wenn es ein problem gibt es noch mal
geld also leben könnte ja müsste man
nicht sagen ja wir müssen uns da wir
werden uns darauf einstellen dass wir
weniger wohlstand haben und weniger geld
für bestimmte dinge jetzt sind wir bei
der gretchenfrage der politik wo ich
immer wieder obwohl über gerhard
schröder jetzt im moment ja nur negativ
geredet wird ihn immer als
beispielgebend dafür dass er eine harte
reform gemacht hat und gesagt hat wir
müssen verzichten aber es wird nach mehr
geben wenn ich sehe wie viel millionen
arbeitsplätze durch die reform bei all
ihren schwächen geschaffen worden sind
wie viel sicherheit für gegebene wie
viel soziale absicherung wir durch diese
reform gegeben haben war es richtig aber
das ergebnis war und das ist bis heute
noch das problem der der sagt wir müssen
uns einschränken kriegt einen in
anführungszeichen auch politische auf
den deckel das wird eine frage sein die
politik beantworten muss wir kriegen das
als fdp ein bestimmter stimme geben aber
eines möchte ich deutlich sagen die
annahme dass wir uns alle einschränken
müssen wenn man habe genau zugehört hat
dann ist da ja noch ein anderer teil wir
müssen nicht verzichten wenn wir in der
lage sind uns zu verändern wenn wir es
schaffen zum beispiel weniger energie
durch richtige investitionen zu
verbrauchen schaffen wir es auf der
gleichen stelle wieder vorteil für uns
so schnell das geht
einfaches beispiel nehmen sie bei wanted
wie schnell es geht das milliarden
umsätze kommen tausende von
arbeitsplätze entstehen millionen von
steuern ich vermute sogar noch viel mehr
als mit dem versteuern kommen es wird an
der frage innovation liegen wird werden
nur den großen fehler machen wenn wir
glauben es geht mit dem alten irgendwie
so weiter das sagen es ist leicht gesagt
wir werden auf wohlstand verzichten
müssen und uns einschränken die frage
ist doch wen trifft das vor allem und
aktuell trifft es vor allem diejenigen
leute die wenig geld haben so diejenigen
mit hohem einkommen sowie alle die hier
am tisch sitzen würde ich mal sagen wir
können diese steigenden energiepreise
und lebensmittelpreise verkraften ja das
ist zwar auch nicht schön aber das
kriegen wir schon hin es gibt aber leute
die da richtig daran zu knapsen haben
und die richtig sorge dafür haben was
ist wenn die strom nach zahlung und so
weiter ein flattern und das heißt wer
muss sich einschränken und wer muss mehr
abgeben und wer muss mehr unterstützung
behalten erhalten und das ist die frage
die wir als regierung dann eben auch
beantworten müssen und weswegen ich
glaube dass über entlastung nachzudenken
und zwar zielgerichtet und nicht mit der
gießkanne der richtige weg aber jetzt
ein am 3 der entlastung und dann wird
wieder teurer also das jetzt also ich
finde ja diese äußerung wir werden alle
ärmer die ist ja schon eine nebelkerze
weil ich habe mir fallen auch schon
darauf hingewiesen dass in der krise die
anzahl der milliardäre gestiegen ist und
wenn nicht jetzt immer noch zu dem thema
oder dem beispiel lebensmittelpreise
zurückkomme also teurer geworden sind
bestimmte grundnahrungsmittel
nudeln eier hackfleisch und preiswerter
geworden in der krise ist champagner
kaviar
das sind natürlich keine
grundnahrungsmittel aber das zeige auch
das ist für bestimmte gruppen sozusagen
viel viel härter ist wenn die preise
steigen als für andere gruppen darum
finde ich das ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen zynisch zu sagen wir werden
alle ärmer werden es gibt das haben alle
krisen gezeigt es gibt leute die gerade
von krisen profitieren auch von der
zustrom von vielen flüchten geflüchteten
menschen haben auch leute profitiert
selbst leute die dagegen sozusagen
öffentlich gewettert haben da haben wir
hier auch beispiel im bundestag gehabt
und alle über einen kamm zu scheren so
zu tun als hätten alles gleich das ist
die frage
der begriff der transformation all das
ist meine frage franken musste und die
politik da nicht auch immer ein stück
doch er ist eben auch bestimmte dinge
feierlichkeit und transparenz sind ganz
wichtig und ich glaube dass die menschen
das auch sehr genau spüren dass es dass
die entscheidungen letztlich
konsequenzen für sie haben und deswegen
ja jetzt haben wir drei monate ist es
günstiger und ab september haben wir
dann auf stand hier weil dann alles dann
doch mehr teurer weil ihr das also fährt
also viele vieles davon wird ein
strohfeuer sein wir hatten das ja vorhin
auch angesprochen ich meine wenn sie
neun euro ticket machen aber kein
zusätzliches wagenmaterial zur verfügung
stellen und nach drei monaten ist alles
wieder wie vorher dann wird es ein
strohfeuer sein und nichts anderes aber
ich glaube das entscheidende ist die
frau große hat davon gesprochen dass
müsse zielgerichtet sein fakt ist die
bundesregierung macht es jetzt nicht
zielgerichtet und sie macht er mit der
gießkanne und versucht jeden der drei
koalitionspartner entsprechend zu
bedenken aber das ist keine
zielgerichtete ausgabe für die zwei
energie
und kostendämpfung pakete werden etwa 30
milliarden euro ausgegeben und da drin
ist zum beispiel sind die zahlung für
die hartz iv empfängerin
hartz-iv-empfänger die entlastet werden
darf der kinder sofort zuschlag drin die
der familienbonus ist da drin der eben
auch für kinder insbesondere
größen geben auch hier irgendwie nicht
zielgerichtet
steuerpflichtig das heißt diejenigen tun
einkommen da wird zwar wieder weg
gesteuert das heißt diejenigen die
geringe einkommen haben sie können davon
auch mehr behalten wohngeld empfängerin
werden entlastet also es ist schon sehr
regel aufgestellt okay wir sind gespannt
wie es weiter geht normalerweise gehört
ja noch jemand drittes dazu nämlich die
grünen aber sie haben hier nur vier
plätze an diesem tisch aber ich freue
mich dass wir wieder vier menschen hier
im studio haben können vielen dank herr
frei vor klose und herr fricke und
vielen dank fürs zuschauen das war die
phoenix runde für diese woche morgen
zeigen wir ihnen das europa puppen bis
dann